tigers handing out personal jerseys to
the taylor north little league world
championship team congratulations boys
on winning the little league world
series what's the coolest thing that's
happened since you guys have won it all
being on field being able to meet all
the players uh talking with them
autographing baseballs and some of us
got bats even and just being able to
talk with them that's pretty cool
congratulations to all those five young
men eric schubert
one of the big three eight and 11 on the
year has not walked more than one in his
last nine games that's a real
good sign the whip is coming down the
strikeouts are coming up and i don't
know if you could have asked for a
better start for any play with a new
team than what marty has done scoople
checks him the one two is swinging a
miss that's the fast ball up they've got
a lot of swings and misses so two out
here's john gomes the right hand to hit
her the payoff to gomes he struck him
out fastball above the strike zone
beautiful pitch 97.
and the other left-hander in this
southpaw hookup making his 26th start of
the season is cole irvin
and kype five innings five innings is
what you're looking at why well a
starting pitchers have tossed five
innings or fewer in 10 of the last 16
ball games one of those ball games cole
irvine's last outing against seattle saw
him go three there's robbie grossman who
played a couple of seasons in oakland
grossman drives one to deep left field
back it goes gone
number 20 for robbie grossman the
breaking ball down and in robbie
grossman is really swung the bat well
from the right hand side scuba facing
matt chapman that's the
147th of the season for terrex scuba and
a new tigers rookie record 87 looks like
a good hard slider after that last
strikeout of matt chapman derek skubal
and company handed the ball to the
authenticator yeah
mark it up into the vault it goes willy
castro at 216 playing left field today
sends one toward right center racing
over pender makes a phenomenal diving
catch a superman play in right center
field to rob willie castro of extra base
hits and he gets the tip of the hat from
cole irvin his pitcher is kenneth racing
toward the alley these right field a
full out dive and parallel to the ground
and hauls it in for the final out here's
matt olson 83 runs driven in for olson
that leads oakland and is second among
major league first basemen
matt olson lines one fair down the third
base line martay will score easily olson
will ease into second with an rbi double
and this game is tied at one here's
chapman and he swings in the first pitch
in a drive deep left center field way
back gone home run
into the seats over the bullpens in left
center field matt chapman home run
number 22 and the a's take a 3-1 lead
an absolute no doubter 423
feet big chance for the tigers here in
the fourth willy castro has a chance
to put the tigers get this thing tied up
or put them ahead
chapman's got it fair ball he's gonna
step on third his throw to first is in
time
it's a double play to keep the tigers
off the board
the stretch
and the powerful arm of matt chapman
first and third nobody out with john
gomes who's been seeing the ball well
against left-handers ready to do some
more damage
it's this one high in the air right
center
grossman over and back he's got it spins
around fires it back in quickly martay
comes in to score john gomes with a
sacrifice fly four to one a's
and two how to run in top of the fifth
oceans at first
and ken is walking bounced out
this one's driven to right that's hit
well grossman's back and that baby's
gone
canna goes the other way a two run shot
mark can i get an oppo taco yes you can
order up very necessary and that is
marqana's 500th career hit
congratulations that's a nice milestone
so three runs in here in the fifth to
make it six to one paul irvin with
some runs to work with as he faces
garnot there we go garneau with a jack
to deep left field
and dustin garneau hits his first homer
as a tiger to lead off the fifth
there we go
he got that one right down to the heart
of the plate
derek hill doubled his last timeout is
the 2-2
deep fly ball left field another solo
shot
derek hill's third bomb of the year and
the tigers are within three just keep
talking the good tuck
[Music]
let the boys
get back into this game two down one on
and here's robbie grossman
grossman with a line shot one hop
harrison backs up throws to first and
that will do it
here's harrison the infield in and
harrison it's a live drive base hit to
left that'll score pender elvis goes to
third and elvis says rounding third
he'll score now the throw comes back in
and going to second harrison's going to
be out at second base and a tag by scope
but josh harrison drives in two in the
eighth and the a's take an 8-3 lead
so two away and here is chapman
matt chapman one for four with a two-run
homer
chapman hits that one deep left center
field and that baby's gone
and what a night for chapman and that's
his second home run and the is taken
nine to three lead
number 23 for the a's third baseman
he's getting hot and bob melvin told us
if we're going to make noise and we're
going to make a run we're going to get
into the postseason
matt chapman has to be a big part of it
and he's becoming a big part of it now
no doubt so on to the top of the order
derek hill
up the middle and that's a base hit for
derek hill
no hustling around to third is castro
jonathan scope
had an infield single last time up 0-2
pitch
chopped to the right side big bounce for
harrison quickly to first and that is
the ball game
so the
six-game road trip
starts out well for the athletics is the
bullpen is terrific tonight and these
use the long ball the offense indeed
comes to life so a good start to the
road trip time of game was two hours and
58 minutes and the final score tonight
from detroit the athletics 9 and the
tigers 3.